Michael Rapport is the commissioner of
our fantasy football league you know he
vowed when he took over he was going to
clean it up and make it good and him and
JD were fighting all weekend over some
stupid technicality stipulation and then
I think JD was pissed because Michael
was a Bravo con all weekend well Michael
it seems like you're getting attacked
now for your fantasy football league
management I'm doing a great job the
league needs cleaning up Howard it's
your lead whether you want to
acknowledge it or not this is I don't
know Howard Stern fantasy football
league it's been corrupt it's been dirty
uh I had to step in JD what is your beef
with Michael
freak so this guy this guy sets up for
the past few years we didn't have an
injured reserve spot where that means
you can put an injured player there
right injured players
an IR spot so Michael advocated for this
uh so we've been doing it and this dummy
text me yesterday or text the whole
league saying you guys are uh over using
to enter deserve you need to drop this
player you need to drop this player no
one cares about the minutia the bottom
line is am running this league starting
today with an iron-clad fit the issue is
he was at Bravo con he couldn't focus on
fantasy football he couldn't focus on
and pick up certain players so he got
pissed and now he wants to change the
rules it's ridiculous Robin my loam I
beat the [ __ ] out of the they had the
monkey Bowl two weeks ago with me versus
Bowie
and I beat you last week
JD asked a question and he is yet to
address it he'll talk about how great a
commissioner is but Michael address the
injured reserve thing yesterday why is
it an issue address okay I'll address
that right now how many points did I
beat you by you big gorilla tooth
reflection he deflects what do you want
to say Richard what do you want to jump
in here I know how to handle Michael I
know how to shut him right down I'm one
of the people he's mad at because I have
a guy in the IR spot that he thinks
shouldn't be there so I was like Michael
spank me punish me I deserve I miss
using the IR thank you I'll speak I'll
have my way with you intimately I've
friend you you know you're not hearing
me up I want to get intimate with you my
friend I've seen you a little [ __ ] I've
seen that rotten little dick
what are you implying here you want to
be nude and spanked by Michael Rapaport
I want him to been I'll be fully nude
Michael can be wearing clothes but I
want him to bend me over his knee and
spank me oh well let me ask you
something let me ask you for Miss using
the eye
rappaport's a pretty you know he's
strong he ain't weakling you imagine how
red and raw your ass will be if he
spanks you I know are you crazy I need
to learn my lesson I'm doing something
wrong
things do I get rich in your kinky freak
you as many as you think it takes for me
to learn my lesson and then I will take
fire Booth out of my IR spot first of
all Richard stinks to high heaven that's
number one and he won't bathe right
I'll stink extra that day
secondly secondly Richard is a
notoriously bad wiper Richard Richard
now you're talking about [ __ ] play man
I'm just he didn't say it I said it well
we can't make it that easy for you my
Michael for coctober Michael's gonna put
you over his leg and he's going to spank
your naked body yes in some way I can
tell you really want this are you is
there a chance you could get hard while
Michael is uh spanking you do you think
you might get a goofy boner to just like
make it funny
after that right what if I come all over
Mike that's what I mean is there a
chance you could come on his leg a
puddle in ravenport's laugh when you get
up
big load you know what I want you to
call me Richard that say dada dada okay
sorry Dada by the way the guys are
telling me here on a note that uh
Richard's ass is covered in zits what's
going on with that monkey pox what do
you got going on back there that is a
good question I don't know I looked at
it recently I'm like man I need some
some Sea Breeze or some kind of thing to
clean my ass cheeks with because they're
very zitty I get sweaty a lot that's
probably it just uh maybe the sweat
causes it
all good luck oh he's gonna be popping
all those zits with this
all right we looked forward to all of
this thank you Michael Rappaport and uh
we'll see what happens when you end up
in the studio uh with Richard and the
spanking whether it becomes sexual we'll
soon find out
come on his shoes yeah where's some old
shoes Michael just in case
[Music]